What's up? How it's happening, everybody?
On Twitter right now, you may have seen there's this platforming game
That's blowing up.
Everyone is talking about this game, so I had to dust off my old Ipad
Find all my old passwords took me 30 minutes. I'm already pissed off
But Pewds, you gotta play this game, it's so difficult
Okay fine, I'll play it!. I'll play the game
I'll play Trap Adventure 2 - never heard of Trap Adventure 1 but apparently Trap Adventure 2 is
...where it's at, everybody. Trap Adventure 2
Pretty funky music, I can dig this, what does this do?
OK!
EZ!!!!!!!!
Alright!. Easy, easy
Great
[Pewds laughs]
Al' right
What is wrong with me?
That's hilarious!. Never seen that before
So I, I gotta trigger this one
oh my god!
what do I do then?
Stoppp... Hoo hoo hooo hhooo
Okay, I get it!
I gotta land on the edge [x2]
Well, that went great!.
Let's try that again
Aight, I see why you wanted me to play this game now
I get it. That's hilarious.
Hey, look at that!
Okay!.
What do we got?
This one!!!
This one...
Oh my god, I can't jump that far...
OK!!!
A'ight
All right and seem...
WOW!!!
HOLY! MOLY!
did you...[laugh],
how did I do that?
[Demonic Pewds] NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Oh my god, I can't do that twice
Stop!
come back here.
Oh, look at that son!
Huhhhh [R.I.P.]
I wanna scream, I wanna scr...[laughs]
Uhhhhh!.
My god!!!
[Window has been shut down :3]
Fantastic!, fantastic!
EAZ...
EAZZYYYY
Trap adventure...
more like
dumb adventure
[OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH]
How do I do that jump?. It's so sick
Whoa!
Where the hell did that come from?
Look at that son.
All right [x4].
Calm down [x2].
It's gonna come
And then... ARRGGHHHHH
That's right!
[r.i.p.]
Can you stop?
Can you leave me alone?
I don't even know how I do this jump honestly. i just...
I've honestly just made it by accident
Look at that!
Okay, okay, okay, okay? OK
Three things are gonna happen
this one,
and then...
I'm just gonna go!
Oh my god!. Oh my god! What's happening?
Noooo!!!
Ahhhhh! [Laughs]
[LAUGHING] GODDAMIT!!
[KEEPS LAUGHING] I hate this game!
Whoa!. Look at!
okay, okay, kay!
NO!
Oh, What do I do?
SHIT!
OK!
GO! GO! GO! GO!
What do I do then?!!!
Ahhhhh!!!
Gooooo!!!
What do I do?!!!
Get the *NO* fuck outta here!
[Fake crying noises]
Oh, It jumps there!
Here it is, Here it is!
Can you stop moving?
Great, great, great, just great!
I would love to do that again.
Thank you for asking. Thank you for asking
I would love to do that again. Thank you for asking
Absolutely!. Will love it
There we go!
Look at that skill!
Look at that skills, son!
Look at this!
YES!!!
Ha, ha! [Victory sound]
Ohhh!!!! [Shocked sound]
You snake!
You try and get me!
where do I go then?
Ehm... (sorry in japanese)
No!!!
*Sarah McLachlan – Angel* [Sad Song]
Oh my god, Oh my god!
Go, Go!
Go, Go, Go!
Go, Go, GOOOOO!!!
*Sarah McLachlan – Angel* [Sad Song, Again]
Ohhhh!
Ahhhh!!!
STOOOOP!!!
[Demonic Pewds] Are you kidding me?
I think, I know what it needs to do...
Look at that!
Easy, Easy, [Diablo Pewds] EAAAA!!!
A' Right!.
What do I do here?
I don't even know what I'm looking at
Block ball game [Arkanoid?]
Whaat?
What do I do?
What?
So, if I hit the left button, It does a ball
Ohhh! I met...it's like a reverse.
It's like a reverse of that old Atari game. [BreakOut]
Oh, God!
Oh, god!
Oh god.
Okay! Okay!
Oh, great!
Fantastic!
Stop!
just, give me...
*Windows XP Shutdown sound*
Just bounce!
Oh, my lord!
Great!
What the frocker?
Great [sigh]
Great, great!
No, that's fine!.
That's fine!.
I wanna do it again!
I WANT to do it again!
It was fun!
I was having fun!
This, this bit sucks!
It just sucks, okay?
Nooo!
I'm- to slow!,
okay, I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine!
Jump off!
What happens if I launch the ball?
Right?
I launch the ball
and then, I jump up
Then, I'm just screwed
Oh, It keeps going!
It kills MEEE!!!
[Laughs]
Okay, all right!
Okay!. Fair enough, fair enough!
Let's keep it on as long as we can...
and then, when we don't think we can do it, I bounce
It's gonna come back, it's gonna.
What in the world is those? (Are those)
What are those?
Am I right?
Okay? Okay? I'm dead
*Windows XD shutdown sound*
Good game, good game everyone!.
At least the music is "A+"
This is some of the best...
...music I've ever heard.
It's Mozart level...
Of...
I can shoot more than one ball
Gr- Fantastic!
Love the ball game!
Love it!
The ball...
BUA!!!
Son of a ball!
What the hell, ball?!
*Seinfeld Theme Song*
Ball, ball!
Ball, ball, ball!
Ball!
BALL, ball, Ball!
Ball!, ball, ball, ball!
"Yo wame ro volleyball?"
"Yo vara, vara a bowl!"
Yo, what a ball!
Hop out!
[Italian Accent] Oh my god, ball everywhere!
There's a ball everywhere [Does cutiepie aprove?]
Come on!
NAAAAA!!!! WHAT'S UP? *Seinfield Theme song*
Bold, bold, bold, for fun...
Yo want me the babold?
Yo, yo yo, for fun [Dumb youtubers impressions?]
bore é bore é le bold
Bored the baboon!
[Swedish stuff] Hej hoppa...!
Peter, Klaus, PETER!
Klaus, Peter...! [I have no Idea what's he saying]
OH, MY GOD I DID IT!!!
[Diablo pewds is back]
God damn, what even is that?!
Just, just leave me alone!
Just leave me alone!
Please!
Plea-!
Oh, no!
Go, go, go!
Go, go!
I can't beat that!
Wha- What do I do then?
What do I do then?
[Monkey-ish sounds]
Ha ha!
[Frustrated Poods]
You're wasting lives, Pewds.
Go, go, go! Watch out.
Oh, it's another one. It's another one. Fantastic.
*Windows XP shutdown sound*
Kill me.
[How do I transcribe this?]
[Cont'd]
Come on [x3]
[Higher pitch] Come on, come on, man.
Come on, you can do it, man, I believe in you.
Come on [x3] Oh, there's a hole!
Gotta find the hole!  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Ahhhhhh!! NO! [Laughs]
Sw- s- s- s- s- s- s- swami! [??]
Ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze--
Ze- ze-
Ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze-
DaaaKk!
Last try!
Ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- [Plz :c]
Pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe-
Damn it! Damn it! Let me go!
Yes!
[Here we go again] Swim- swi- swi- swim-
Ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- [plz stop]
Ze- ze- ze- ze- YAAAAAOOOOoo--I hate you!
NO!
Ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze-
Pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe- pe-
Pe- pe- AHH!
[Swedish:] Damn!
Ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- ze- fu- fu- fu- fu-
Fu- fu- fu- fu-
My god, it's ridiculous. This ga-
My god, it's skip one, okay? [Something inaudible]
What the hell, man? Now you're just being mean, that's just really mean.
*Sigh*
Where the hell do I go?
Come on. Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's still impossible.
Damn it.
Go down, you *weird shout* son of a s-
Are you kidding me?
Thank you for watching this video, if you enjoyed leave a like and as always don't play this game; don't play it.
No one should play. It. Don't worry about it. Okay. Don't play it. Do not play it. Don't play this game
No one should play this game
This game is why there's evil in the world, this game is why there's hatred in the world,
whoever made this game needs to d... [rip]
And thank you for watching this family-friendly video. As always, smash that like and subscribe.
I don't-- God damn it.